uh matthew thank you for the kind
introduction thank you for
attending today um i know it is cliche
but i hope you believe me when i say
what an honor
it is to appear at a hillsdale
college forum one this kirby center is
just a magnificent
facility and i just believe the work of
hillsdale college is
indispensable to the cause of
liberty in america i can't tell you how
many different years i have always
looked forward to receiving
my copy of in primus there's nothing
else quite
like it out there but i am very much
delighted to be
invited to speak to you today
as i look around the audience some of
you i haven't seen since the summer i
hope you have had a good
summer personally we had a rather
momentous
summer in the hensarling family i think
it was july when my
wife called me and said it is time to
have a serious discussion about getting
a
pet for the children
so i engaged in what i thought was a
serious discussion with my wife saying
okay we live in dallas i work in
washington
you're a carpool mom do we really need
another mouth
to feed surely there's other ways we can
make our children
happy so about a week later
i get a call from the wife okay we're at
the pet shelter do you want a cat or a
dog
yes freedom of choice so i said okay
well
i lost round one we have a covered porch
we could put the doghouse there
large backyard the dog could run around
with apologies to all the cat people in
the audience not really a cat person
they scratch all the furniture i really
don't want to pay for that if we're
going to get a pet let's
get a dog okay well we're just looking
today
so next thing i know i'm literally in
the midst of a
hearing and believe it or not
occasionally i will look at my
blackberry
during a hearing and next thing i know i
open an attachment from my wife there is
a picture of a cat
i text her back and say please tell me
that is not our cat
to which she texts back his name is
grayson isn't he cute
so anyway i finally get home back to
dallas and we have this discussion and i
say uh okay
melissa we talked about the pet i lost
there we talked about
the dog i clearly lost there
you know i'm not feeling too good about
all this and she said jab
you know as a republican member of
congress in washington surely you've
grown accustomed to
speaking and having your views ignored
so anyway freedom to choose you're free
to ignore
what i have to say today i hope you
choose not to ignore
what i have to say today and now i think
i have gotten the frivolity out of
my system to say that one thing we can't
ignore
are the very ominous and daily headlines
that we read today
about very ominous foreign threats to
our safety
and our security that emanate from four
way capitals
from places like moscow damascus tripoli
and tehran and as real and serious
as these foreign threats are we must not
lose sight of the domestic
threats to our freedom and our
prosperity that emanate from another
capital
much closer to home and that is the
capital we find ourselves in today
washington d.c now some of the domestic
threats may appear less evident in the
short term but over time they
are corrosive to our constitution and
individual to
our well-being and our prosperity
none of us can ever ever lose
sight of james madison's famous
observation
that quote there are more instances of
the abridgement
of the freedom of the people by gradual
and silent encroachment by those in
power
and by violent and sudden use of
patience
today i want to speak about one such
threat it is a threat that has grown
markedly worse over the last six years
but i still believe it receives
far too little attention and that is the
threat which is
posed by the rise of what some have
termed the fourth
branch of government namely omnipotent
ubiquitous
agency government which i believe has
clearly made us less prosperous less
entrepreneurial less optimistic
and a less free society today a record
number of americans more than 46 million
of our fellow countrymen find themselves
dependent on food stamps
median household income is down by more
than two thousand dollars in real terms
since january of 09 and working
americans are obviously having to pay
more at the pump
and more at the grocery store the
so-called obama
non-recovery recovery is now officially
the slowest
weakest in the last 70 years
one of the reasons that we are a less
prosperous
society is because we are a less
entrepreneurial society
america is less entrepreneurial now than
at any point in the last
three decades according to a recent
report
of the brookings institution new
business startups are again
at their lowest level in 30 years
the breaking authors of the study went
on to say that
the decline in if the decline in
entrepreneurship continues america
will suffer quote a continuation of slow
growth for the
indefinite future less prosperity and a
depressed entrepreneurial spirit has
also made us a less
optimistic people americans increasingly
believe
that our best days are behind us
according to the most recent wall street
journal nbc news paul
71 believe our country is headed in the
wrong direction
60 believe the u.s is in a state of
decline
and profoundly when asked if life for
our children's generation
will be better than it has been for us
76 percent
76 percent say today do not have such
confidence
sadly it is an all-time high in a
washington post column recently with the
depressing headline quote americans
optimism is
dying one commentator took a deep dive
into the poll
results and found that the lack of
confidence cuts across every economic
status every
gender every race every age and every
ideology it touches
all of us among our fellow citizens is
monica alexander
an african-american single mom who's one
of the nearly eight
million americans today who have not
found a full-time job and have to settle
for part-time work
quote it's been a struggle to keep food
in the house to keep gas in the car she
says
her son asked her mom do we really have
to live like this
or dominic fennell for 15 years dominic
earned a six-figure salary for his
family as a book illustrator but for the
past
four years he's only been able to find
part-time jobs
i'm panicking he says all i think about
is looking
for work americans growing
lack of faith in the future is
disturbing and it is fundamentally
un-american in the sense that it is so
out of character
for us as a people
and it corresponds not only to our
current economic
hard times but to the perceptible loss
of freedom in america today indeed the
heritage foundation's index of economic
freedom records a loss of freedom here
during every single year of the obama
administration
heritage attributes our erosion of
freedom to the loss of
property rights a decline in the rule of
law and the substantial growth
in the size and scope of the federal
government
americans are beginning to take note a
pew research poll last year found for
the first time a majority of the public
says that the federal government
threatens their personal rights
and their freedoms perhaps as
my 10 year old might say ding
ding ding they got it right
it's not lost on them that washington
now decides what their children's
teachers can teach what kind of light
bulbs they're allowed to buy what credit
cards they can put in their wallet or
whether they can
even choose their own doctor
ladies and gentlemen i think perhaps the
very first step in regaining our
prosperity is to appreciate the critical
role
that entrepreneurship has played in our
history
and in economic growth now we while
researching this subject i was pleased
to discover
that hillsdale had already done much of
the work for me
when they published arthur john still
gordon's speech on the very same subject
and in primus earlier this year
parenthetically
one more reason you should always read
in primus
anyway we should all recall collectively
that colonists came to america not just
for religious liberty and not just for
political liberty but they came for
economic liberty
as well several of the colonies is
massachusetts bay plymouth and virginia
were founded
not by the crown but by profit-seeking
corporations
others including pennsylvania and
maryland were founded by proprietors
and profit was the primary reason the
dutch founded new york
and settled in manhattan indeed gordon
said in his hillsdale remarks quote so
been on making money were the dutch
that they did not get around to building
a church for 17 years
worshiping instead at the fort
this entrepreneurial drive helps explain
why the 13
colonies were the richest place on earth
on a per capita basis
by the time we declared our independence
so from the earliest beginnings of the
republic we have always been a land
of the entrepreneur the dreamer and the
risk taker and yes
that includes the risk of failure
someone who clearly understood this was
steve jobs
the famous co-founder of apple in an
interview before he died jobs said quote
i look at myself as sort of a trapeze
artist
the reporter asked him with or without a
net jobs replied
without because chief steve jobs was a
risk taker apple became one of the most
valuable companies
in the world whose innovations continue
to revolutionize
our lives another entrepreneurial risk
taker is robin chase the co-founder of
zipcar
the largest car sharing company in the
world
when she launched zipcar in 2000 she was
left with 78
in her bank account it was preposterous
a ridiculous thing to do she said
but it worked zipcar became a
quintessential business success and 13
years later the company sold to avis for
a half
a billion dollars but what's so
important about the story of these two
entrepreneurs
is not the amount of money they were
able to make for themselves
it was about the ability to build
successful
companies and to pursue happiness
their god-given right to pursue
happiness and because they did
millions millions of other people were
able to enjoy
products and have jobs and put a roof
over their
head but it's not just the famous
entrepreneurs
it's the small business entrepreneurs in
every single small
city in village in berg around america
small business people like rick carmona
who lives in the fifth district of texas
that i have the
privilege to represent in congress it
was over 30 years ago that rick
started his own mexican food restaurant
carmonas if you're ever in terrell texas
i highly recommend it to you
his mother was the cook when they first
started and for several years
rick did everything else he said quote
we didn't make much money for a long
time
but i never gave up i just kept working
at it
but folks something is changing in
america today fewer and fewer people
are deciding to do what rick did people
are giving
up they're no longer working at it
to use the words of my small businessman
in east texas the spirit of free
enterprise of entrepreneurial risk
taking and dream chasing that is defined
as
as a people regrettably seems to be
fading away
robert samuelson of the washington post
wrote a recent column headline where
have all the entrepreneurs
gone after analyzing brookings institute
data he wrote that
u.s economy is increasingly dominated by
older firms rather than new startups
and this is a phenomenon that is quite
unusual in our nation's history
and it is a trend that can be seen in
every state and industrial sector
in our nation fewer entrepreneurs taking
fewer risk
leads to fewer jobs it is that
simple so what's causing this disturbing
lack of entrepreneurial risk-taking in
america
economists at the university of maryland
and the census bureau have written quote
the cumulative effect of regulations
is a prime suspect and discriminates
against new businesses by favoring
established firms
that have the experience and resources
to deal with it
listen to the words of bernie marcus
co-founder of home depot quote
having built a small business into a big
one i can tell you that today
the impediments that the government
imposes are impossible to deal with
home depot would never have succeeded if
we tried to start it today
every day you see rules and regulations
from a group of washington bureaucrats
who know
nothing about running a business and i
mean every day
it's become stifling last year a page
one story in the wall street journal
declared
quote a risk-adverse culture had
infected our economy and was harming
u.s workers the story generated a lot of
discussion
among the newspapers readers many
responded with their own personal
stories
and views one reader wrote quote
government has expanded exponentially
creating self-sustaining bureaucracies
that busy themselves with rules
and regulations imposed on essentially
the private sector
putting the bar higher at every turn
exhausting
entrepreneurs energies and meaningless
for on
meaningless formalities and bleeding
them with ever increasing
social burdens now i don't need to read
a newspaper to hear this angst and this
anxiety i hear it every day
in the 5th congressional district of
texas typical is what i heard from a
small
business person also from terrell texas
named hal
he said jeb the greatest risk i worry
about is that someday my business will
be destroyed by osha
epa irs or the department of labor
it's not an exaggeration the reason so
many small business folks worry about
these risks is that most of us know
we cannot defend ourselves a business
that is rightfully or wrongfully
the target of one of these agencies is
completely outgunned in terms
of resources he told me and i'll never
forget the day
and a businessman at a small cabinetry
shop in palestine texas
he came up to me to discuss
closing his business he said congressman
it got to the point
in dealing with all the federal
regulations it just got to the point
where i thought my federal government
didn't want me to succeed the business
closed
dozen or more people lost their jobs so
while the american people
are being told repeatedly that nothing
is getting done in washington
entrepreneurs and small businesses all
across our land
know differently they know better than
anyone that the federal
bureaucracy is busier than ever
last year washington set a new record by
issuing final rules consuming 26
417 pages in the federal register
not one not one of them voted on by
congress
another 3 305 regulations are moving
through the pipeline at the historic
rate of roughly
one new regulation every two hours
twenty four seven three hundred and
sixty five
whether it's the twenty plus pages
needed to define what a retail
pet store is to rules concerning the
interstate movement of
char real avocados to the thousands of
pages
comprising the federal takeover of our
health care
system every washington regulation
has an impact on our struggling economy
every washington regulation
impacts the ability of some needy
american to get a job
and let's also remind ourselves
regrettably
many of these regulations are written
to protect established businesses from
future
competition one study estimates the
overall financial cost of regulatory
compliance and its economic impact has
now reached almost two trillion dollars
annually
which translates into an annual hit of
approximately fifteen thousand dollars
to household budgets
and more than ten thousand per employee
to small
business budgets ladies and gentlemen
i do not recall ever in my lifetime with
the challenges
of upward mobility and economic
opportunity
for low and moderate income americans
have been greater
not surprisingly i also do not ever
recall in my lifetime
when the bureaucratic regulatory red
tape burdens
on our entrepreneurs our risk takers our
small businesses
have been greater as well the evidence
is
overwhelming there is a clear causal
direct link
between the two and as costly
in financial terms as this regulatory
onslaught is the true cost has to be
measured otherwise
and it's not even measured in the harm
to the entrepreneurial spirit no the
true
cost of the rise of agency government is
far more profound
the loss of personal freedom
is what many term the fourth branch of
government has risen due process
checks and balances and separation of
powers all cornerstones
of our political liberties have waned
now the rise of the fourth branch of
government is not a new phenomenon
in any respect as heritage scholar
robert moffat notes it began in the
early 20th century when progressives
became disillusioned
with our constitution they believe that
its purpose of securing individual
rights through limited government
and its structure of separated powers
could no longer meet the needs
of a modern world and in short term they
advocated for the application of what
they called a
new science and they pushed for creation
of
bureaus to be staffed by non-partisan
social scientists armed with massive
amounts of data and procedures
for eradicating all of society's
perceived deals
herbert crowley who is a leading
progressive voice in the wilson era
noted that new agency government quote
exercises an authority
which is in part legislative and impart
judicial it is simply a
convenient means of consolidating the
divided activities of government
to certain practical social purposes
madison and federalist 47 had a very
different take
he wrote quote the combination of all
power legislative executive
and judiciary in the same hands may
justly be pronounced
the very definition of tyranny
the seed of this form of tyranny was
planted during the wilson administration
bloom during fdr's
new deal became overgrown in lbj's great
society and has now reached crisis
proportions
under president obama our chief
executive who possesses both pin
and phone but regrettably lacks a copy
of the constitution this century-long
progressive expansion of government has
unleashed the modern regulatory state as
we know it
extremely powerful extremely intrusive
terribly opaque
baffinly bureaucratic distinctively
undemocratic
and alarmingly unaccountable
as we all know article 1 section 1 of
our constitution states all legislative
powers here in granted shall be vested
in a congress in a congress thus when
congress
delegates its fundamental legislative
authority to unelected
unaccountable bureaucracy it is arguably
acted
in an unconstitutional manner and as it
does the people's right to both
self-government
and due process is undermined the
citizens right to carefully deliberate
proposed
legislation through representatives in
congress becomes reduced
to nothing more than a mere notice
in comment period a period when
citizens are permitted to lodge
complaints and suggestions
all of which the unelected bureaucrats
are free to ignore
and all of which the unelected
bureaucrats may use
to retaliate in federalist
52 madison wrote the definition of the
right of suffrage is very
justly regarded as a fundamental article
of republican government
but who elected the legions of
bureaucrats who now have become
legislator
cop on the beat prosecutor judge jury
and often compensated victim
all rolled in to one the public
even rarely knows their names
today americans are less and less
governed by the rule of law and more and
more governed by the discretion
of regulators it is osha now not
congress that governs our workplace
safety it is the epa now
not congress that governs over our air
quality it is hhs now not congress
that governs over our health care and
most alarmingly
to our economic opportunity and economic
liberty
it is now the bureaucratic progeny of
dodd-frank that rules over
our financial markets jonathan macy of
the yale law school was most precedent
when he noted that quote laws
classically provide people with the
rules
dodd-frank is not directed at people it
is an outline directed at bureaucrats
and instructs them to make still more
regulations and to create
more bureaucracies specifically after
weighing in at over 2000 pages
dodd-frank demands 400 new mandates be
promulgated
and multiple new agencies be spawned
two of the most worrisome of these
agencies are the orwellian
named consumer financial protection
bureau
otherwise known as the cfpb and the
financial stability oversight council
known
as fsoc both operate largely out of
public view
both are subject to virtually no checks
and balances and both
have been granted sweeping unilateral
powers to fundamentally control huge
swaths
of the american economy arguably cfpb
is the single most powerful and least
accountable federal agency
in our republic's history it clearly
operates outside our constitutional
system of checks
and balances cfpb or more specifically
its
one unelected director has almost
absolute
discretionary power to find any consumer
product
quote unquote abusive and thus
fundamentally outlaw it
so when it comes to our credit cards our
auto loans
our mortgages of us and our fellow
citizens the cfpb has unbridled
power not only to make them less
available
and more expensive but to absolutely
take
them away and in so doing the cfpb
is fundamentally unaccountable to the
president because
its director can only be removed for
cause
it is fundamentally unaccountable to
congress because the cfpb's funding is
not
subject to appropriations the cfpb is
fundamentally unaccountable to the
courts because
dodd-frank requires courts to grant the
cfpb
deference regarding its interpretation
of federal
consumer financial law thus
cfpb is regrettably unaccountable to the
american people
one of the classic hallmarks of agency
government
all of us familiar with the axial axiom
that absolute power corrupts and
absolute power corrupts
absolutely such is the case at the cfpb
which is why there are
newspaper stories with headlines like
quote
bureaucrats gone wild cfpb is rife with
discrimination
employees say and cfpb's renovation
costs skyrocket to 216 million
inspector general sees no basis for it
additionally the cfpb is engaged in one
of the most sweeping data collections of
personal private financial records
our nation has ever seen it is an effort
that i assure you rivals
the data collection of the nsa but
regrettably
there is no one at the cfpb who can be
voted out of office
there is no one at the cfpb to be held
accountable now let's take a quick look
at
fsoc fsoc is an amalgamation of
regulators heading agencies that either
helped cause the financial crisis
or were largely negligent in preventing
it notwithstanding they had the
regulatory
power to do so dodd-frank rewards their
failures by granting them the most
sweeping powers over our capital markets
since the new deal dodd-frank allows
federal regulators to unilaterally
define
vague statutory terms like systemic risk
financial stress and financial stability
and by so doing
allows fsoc to dictate capital standards
product mix
lending activities of major financial
firms throughout the u.s
economy they are even empowered
to break them up as aei scholar peter
wallison summarized the f sox authority
is in effect
a blank check to consign to federal
regulation
any large firm the government wants to
regulate
ladies and gentlemen this is nothing
short of a functional
occupation of our economy
by federal regulators who are now
empowered
to do central planning all of this
all of this is being done outside a
public view
with the exception of agencies dealing
and classified information relating to
national security fsoc may
may very well be the nation's least
transparent
federal entity the public cannot view
their proceedings because two-thirds of
them
are conducted in private executive
sessions
better markets a washington organization
that consistently added advocates for
more regulation of our financial system
said
f-sox proceedings make the polit bureau
look open by comparison
no one in america even knows who they
are at the few open meetings they have
they snap their fingers and it's over
and they're all scripted they treat
their information as if it were state
secrets
it's obvious that those who drafted
dodd-frank
fear risk-taking and innovation but as a
society
if we trade freedom for safety in the
long run
we get neither and we are less
prosperous
in the offing the raison de tour
of dodd-frank was the risk of the shadow
banking system
yet a far greater danger to our freedom
and prosperity is posed
by the shadow regulatory system
as university of chicago professor
jerome rajan wrote in his book fault
lines we have to recognize
that the only true safe financial system
is a system that does not take risk
that does not finance innovation or
growth that does not help draw people
out of poverty and that gives consumers
little
choice and yes that's exactly what we
see
in america today as washington tries to
regulate
risk out of existence there is less
innovation
less growth more poverty
that's our america so ladies and
gentlemen
our nation faces a great challenge
but we have faced great challenges
before and i
am optimistic about the future of
america and you should be
as well i know it is cliche to say that
it is darkest
before the dawn but what an opportunity
we have before us because rarely in our
lifetimes
have the failures of big government
liberalism
been more evident than they are today
what an opportunity before us
so what we need today more than in any
time
in the last generation is a return to
our
country to its first principles of
personal
liberty and limited government what we
need today using the title of
hillsdale's
matthew spalding's best seller is for us
to loudly and pro
and proudly proclaim yes we still
hold these truths to be self-evident
a return to first principles first
congress must reaffirm the primacy
of congressional authority in article 1
of the constitution
congress must end the practice of
delegating law making authority to
unelected
unaccountable agency government no more
passing vague laws that direct agencies
to fill
in the blanks with specifics
according to their discretion the reins
act
which has passed the house would
introduce both constitutionality
and accountability into the system by
requiring
congress not the bureaucracy but
congress to approve
all major new regulations the act is
simple
the act is profound the act is
revolutionary and its ultimate passage
into law must be
a major priority of the conservative
movement
secondly members of congress must take
back from the fourth branch of
government the power
of the purse granted in sections eight
nine of article one of the constitution
if you grab a bureaucracy by its budget
its heart in mind very well
will soon follow thirdly congress must
rediscover and reinvigorate the 10th
amendment in order to reinstitute
federalism
one of the cornerstones of our
constitutional system
as most here are familiar madison wrote
in federalist 45 the powers delegated to
the federal
government are few and defined those
which are to remain in state governments
are numerous
and indefinite finally
we must celebrate celebrate the role
of risk-taking as an american right
as an american heritage and as an
american
destiny we must educate our fellow
citizens that when we entrust government
agencies to manage our
risk we risk we risk
losing both our freedom and our
prosperity
now all this will require strong and
dedicated
consistent cheerful leadership in
washington
and in every great capital and county
seat
across america everyone has a role to
play
no one can be a passive observer
as for me i intend not just to
participate i intend to
lead but at the end of the day the
future of our great people
does not rest in my hands and it
certainly does not rest in the hands of
the united states
congress i'm reminded of jefferson's
message to madison
the people are the only sure alliance
for the preservation
of liberty and that's the true reason
i'm optimistic
because the american people are anxious
but they're not hopeless
they may have lost faith in washington
but they name
they have not lost faith in america
and with the help of institutions like
hillsdale college
they never will and we will soon get our
republic
back thank you very much
thank you thank you uh mr angelina that
was uh
a wonderful talk laying out a an
argument what is going on and what to do
about it
precisely what i'd like to encourage
here we have some time for some
questions and have some discussion
uh with the congressman before he has to
to go back
sir
congressman i'd be more very interested
in what you would see as steps one two
and three assuming
that we get a republican house
a republican senate and a republican
president
in 2016. well i like your
assumption having said that i
stand before you as the son and grandson
of chicken
farmers so i don't quite count my
chickens before they
hatch but we still dream big dreams
in america um i'm running for
re-election
in the fifth district of texas i hope i
get an opportunity to continue to be
chairman of the house financial services
committee so they're not going to elect
me
senate majority leader but i would
to answer your question make it a very
high
priority in order to rein
in agency government the passage of
the reins act i think that would be
incredibly important
many of you know i have also labored
tirelessly
along with my dear friend and our great
champion of our cause paul ryan to try
to take america off the road to
bankruptcy
as paul has put it probably the most
foreseeable
crisis in america's history
ultimately in order to do that you're
going to have to promote
fundamental economic growth and you're
going to have to reform
current entitlement programs for future
generations
so that bespeaks of a tax code that is
fair
flattering simpler more competitive
and hopefully irs free
and it speaks of the premium support
system
that paul ryan has authored and
championed is
our entitlement reform
so that's two of the three anyway right
there
now quite realistically i think in
divided government
that our chances to advance the cause of
freedom and prosperity
it's probably going to be worked through
our appropriations
system with what are known as
appropriations writers
i don't spend a whole lot of quality
time with our president
but i'm having a hard time believing
he's going to have some kind of epiphany
in the last two years of his
administration and regret all the
different ways that he has made us poor
and less free so
reclaiming the power of the purse is
critical to reclaiming our country and
so
not exactly sure what s3 would be but
it might be some kind of appropriations
bills
that begins to take us in the step in
the right direction i think i think
if the objective the larger objective is
to
pull back delegated power into congress
again
and there'll be many majors that will
require more legislative aggressiveness
if you will
that would demand a president that would
be agreeable to allowing that to play
out you you want to have a normal
legislative process and regain that
control isn't that the
central objective it is the central
objective i would say
i don't recall a time where
so much power has been yielded from we
the people
uh to their government and then from
article
one to article two and then frankly from
article 2 to the non-existent fourth
branch of government
so and frankly both parties have been
guilty
when republicans had the white house
there was a piling on hey it's our guy
in the white house let's go
give him some of our legislative power
but again the the um the the separation
uh of powers is one of the cornerstones
of our liberty and so one re-instituting
um congress as a equal branch of
government
and i think as we know i think there's a
reason the founders made it article one
but to at least reassert that primacy
is is critical
thank you i have a question for you
about the short-term reauthorization
of the export-import bank and the
continuing resolution
you weren't thralled by my speech
i loved it i thought it was great um you
really led the fight
against reauthorization of the
export-import bank so i hope i'm still
leading
it still leading excuse me do you see
this as a victory for conservatives
first and foremost and secondly have you
gotten any
reassurance from leadership that this
will be the last reauthorization of the
bank
before june well i do not confuse
motion with progress and i do not
confuse progress
with victory so i view
an opportunity to decouple the
expiration
date of the export import bank
to decouple that from the expiration of
a continuing resolution to be progress
i believe the fate of the export import
bank
it should stand or fall
on its own so
i'm not enamored of
this particular
continuing resolution
um if i had my druthers
this would not be what would be before
me but i learned very
early on in my congressional career i
don't get to vote on what i want to vote
on i have to vote on what's in front of
me and so
uh i intend to support it assuming it
comes
to the floor i do not believe that
xm should be part of the cr i regret
that
our republican conference is putting it
there but i do think
that for those of us who believe that
although this agency
is small in scope it is incredibly
important
in principle and direction
that members ought to have an
opportunity to understand the issue
debate the issue
and again have xm stand or fall under
its own weight
and ultimately this cr will serve that
purpose
so it's not the first time i've
swallowed hard in my congressional
career
sure it's uh jeff barrett and uh there's
an organization in town called the
medicine coalition which is proposing a
uh
another approach to this agency
government problem and that is
that uh a state
based state run using article five uh
constitutional amendment that's
uh would be initiated by the states uh
which would say that
if 25 of the uh any house of congress or
if 25 percent of the states were
objected to a particular regulation that
that they could force congress to
actually vote on that regulation and
actually do their job
now this this would be do it be an end
run around congress and the president
because it would be started from the
states using their article five power in
the constitution
now um you would obviously need a lot of
states
but if the reigns act is not passed this
might be one way around it and i'm just
wondering what you might think of that
idea because it's
it's just another focus of power to try
to get this thing solved well i haven't
studied the idea
uh carefully but again i take the
threat of the rise of
of the unelected unaccountable agency
government very seriously
so i would want to explore all means
possible
to reign it in to preserve our liberty
and our prosperity but
any constitutional amendment as you know
is heavy heavy lifting
when i was speaking to the other
gentleman about s1 s2 and s3 i talked
about
a flat tax my personal policy preference
for example would be the
fair tax but unless you repealed the
16th amendment i fear you would end up
like europe end up with both so
as a more practical matter
i'm kind of a flat tax guy in the real
world i have to take
um i have to take the world as i find it
not always as i want it to
be so uh certainly explore the idea
and uh what states need to do
to reinvigorate the 10th amendment um
as we say in my neck of the woods god
bless texas and
god bless the rest of them as well
sounds like you've already been
challenged and i i think you you
you may have heard a similar question of
the cato institute last fall
in 1971 the us abandoned its obligation
under the bretton woods agreement to
provide redeemability to foreign
governments in gold of u.s currency they
accumulated
since then we've been able to inflate
our currency infinitely because it's
backed by
the petro dollar which we enforce
militarily
the founders very much andrew jackson
when he ended the second bank of the u.s
said that the circulating money of gold
and silver coin
was intended to prevent the wealth of
the laboring class from being inflated
away
by the corporations working with the
politicians and financiers
serving corporatism which it's the
corporatism that's creating the
regulations that empower the
central planning so doesn't it all go
back to following the money like we
learned in watergate and
do we need to restore a constitutional
system of money and also a new bretton
woods agreement
to be fair with other nations my how the
time has flown
a serious subject deep subject one i'm
not
in a position to
address um with the seriousness that it
deserves
at the moment listen we have a number of
challenges
with a fiat currency which our nation
has had for quite some time
and our financial services committee
will do is continuing a lot of work
as part of our federal reserve
centennial oversight
project um
can't completely tell you where
the project is headed and will
ultimately
end we have done our first piece of
legislation one of many to follow
so dealing with sound
money is a very important issue not
prepared to go into it in detail today
i must admit there's a thousand ways to
advance the cause of
freedom and opportunity and on any given
day
i may be able to work on two or three
not quite working on that issue today
which is not to say it is not
important and i hope it will receive
greater attention should i remain
chairman of the house financial services
committee
on the challenges again to our economy
that is posed by our
current fiat system of currency anyway
thank you thank you very much
uh thank you mr chairman for uh very
fine remarks very thoughtful remarks
um about our current situation some of
your thoughts about how to get out of
that i appreciate that
i would like to before you run off as
you do
i want to thank you for your service on
behalf of hillsdale college we're very
thankful for that
and the work you're doing to to direct
the country work the statesman
you're always welcome in hillsdale here
here and on the main campus so i have a
hillsdale tie for you
thank you thank you very much i think
it'll work